bonjour tu es nouvel étudiant oui on aimerait
t'aider sevenoaks est le dernier des
slug sept à aller étudiante une ambiance de
barbiers masculins et prédomine on
va changer tout ça tu sais
quel est le problème majeur de la
vie sociale contemporaine  la tendance à toujours chercher
quelqu'un de plus cool que soi hé nos
aspirations ont été basiques prendre un gars
qui n'a pas réalisé tout son potentiel
quelqu'un comme Frank oui et ensuite
l'aider à le réaliser ou enfin il y a
assez de matériel ici pour une vie de
travail social nous'  J'essaie également de faire une
différence dans la vie des gens et une façon
d'y parvenir est de les empêcher de se suicider,
aucun cas n'est trop difficile ou
trop difficile, voudriez-vous un beignet,
pensez-vous que je vais me suicider et vous faire
mal paraître ?  j'ai peur que tu
te suicides et que tu te fasses mal paraître en
parlant de prévention du suicide avoir un
petit ami vraiment des compliments du gars
au bar ce que tu as décrit est un
playboy ou une opération ou une opération de déplacement était
comme ça' à éviter  Selon vous, quels
sont les moyens les plus efficaces pour
lutter contre la dépression ? La bière, pas de bière, c'est un
déprimant, les cocktails, les alcools forts et les spiritueux,
c'est ce qui vous donne vraiment une liste comme si je le
savais bêtement, mais c'est un rat, un
opérateur de playboy, je n'avais pas réalisé que je ne le savais pas
vraiment.  comme le mot déprimé, je préfère
dire que je suis en chute libre Je suppose que
maintenant je voudrais aussi les beignets,
c'est pour lui donner l'amour de sa vie tu
le fais non non je ne t'ai jamais vraiment vu